schauen jetzt auf einen der bekanntesten
und gefährlichsten kriminellen klaren
ziel in deutschland den abou chaker clan
jetzt prozess in bochum vom landgericht
auf der anklagebank dort der sohn von
arafat abou chaker vom kopf dieser
klaren familie zum ersten mal steht er
dieser sohn dieses clan chefs vom
richter und das ist der grund razzia im
november letzten jahres brutaler
überfall und vergewaltigung mehrere
prostituierte
darum geht es heute bei diesem prozess
gegen den sohn des clan-chefs abou
chaker abou chaker das ist diese
kriminelle familie
arafat abou chaker geboren in berlin 46
jahre alt geschieden vater von fünf
kindern
angeblich ist er gelernter kfz
mechaniker angeblich ist er unternehmer
fest steht er gilt als führungsfigur des
abou chaker clans
die palästinensische familie flieht vor
dem bürgerkrieg im libanon nach
deutschland und dänemark inzwischen hat
allein der berliner zweig der
großfamilie laut polizeiangaben bis zu
300 mitglieder razzien auf dem
grundstück von arafats millionen villa
im brandenburgischen kleinmachnow stehen
gefühlt auf der tagesordnung
immer wieder machen die armut
schlagzeilen 1 voran chaker boss arafat
2008 übernimmt er das management von
deutsch rapper bushido zehn jahre später
endet die zusammenarbeit aktuell
streiten sie auch hier vor gericht
seit 2020 läuft der prozess gegen arafat
und seine brüder es geht um versuchte
schwere räuberische erpressung
gefährliche körperverletzung
freiheitsberaubung
beleidigung bushido wirft dem clan vor
ihn eingesperrt mit flasche und stuhl
beworfen zu haben arafat abou chaker
seine brüder seine cousins seine
clan-mitglieder die großfamilie steht
regelmäßig mit einem bein im knast
vorwürfe wegen schutzgelderpressung
drogen und waffenhandel geldwäsche
zuhälterei körperverletzung
nun steht erstmalig auch arraf
aktionszeit vor dem richter wegen
brutalen überfall und vergewaltigung
mehrerer prostituierte in recklinghausen
und für uns war im prozess ist unser
chef reporter frank schneider wir
schalten live nach bochum frank kam es
heute schon gehört zum ersten mal steht
arafat abou chaker schon jetzt vor
gericht man könnte annehmen dass da
schon eine menge clan angehörige heute
an dir vorbei gelaufen sind
ja und das ist die große überraschung
ist es besser wenn überhaupt gar keiner
hier es geht eben um site den
19-jährigen sohn von arafat und deswegen
waren auch viele davon ausgegangen dass
hier klar ein angehöriger aus berlin
anreisen bislang ist das nicht so hier
ist es wirklich sehr leer auf den
gerichtsfluren die justiz hat sich
vorbereitet es sind viele justizwache
hier auch mit besonderer ausstattung mit
mit schusssicheren westen um eben für
einen möglichen ansturm gerüstet zu sein
doch der ist wirklich ausgeblieben neben
ihr steht jetzt michael hug er ist der
landgerichtssprecher hier in bochum
harry aqua sind genau die vorwürfe in
dem prozess wirft man den vier
angeklagten darunter den den busacca
sand denn vor mit die vorwürfe der
anklage
gehen dahin dass man an insgesamt vier
überfällen auf prostituierte in
recklinghausen beteiligt gewesen sein
soll bei diesen überfällen soll es nicht
nur zu raubtaten sondern auch zu
besonders schweren sexuellen übergriffen
zum nachteil der geschädigten gekommen
sein im rahmen dieser taten sollen
insbesondere auch gefährliche werkzeuge
eingesetzt worden sein teleskop
schlagstöcke und auch schein waffen und
zudem sollen auch freiheitsberaubung
begangen dort sein wo die frauen denn
bei diesen taten auch verletzt nach den
mir vorliegenden informationen sind die
geschädigten auch verletzt worden ja
danke herr reha und dazu muss man auch
sagen diese frauen sind natürlich in
diesem verfahren ganz ganz wichtige
zeugen und da gibt es natürlich ein
großes problem was man bei prozessen
gegen die familie botschafter immer
wieder erlebt hat diese frauen soll
mittlerweile angeblich gegenüber den
ermittlern schweigen und da gibt es den
verdacht und auch ein
ermittlungsverfahren bei der
staatsanwaltschaft dass diese opfer
eingeschüchtert worden sind von
familienmitgliedern es war sogar die
rede davon dass der vater arafat abou
chaker selber diese prostituierten
versucht hat einzuschüchtern das 7 nicht
aussagen sollen oder jedenfalls nicht
sein sohn und die mitangeklagten
belasten sollen da muss man jetzt mal
abwarten ein gleich die anklage verlesen
ist muss man sehen wie der prozess
weitergeht ob diese zeugen hier aussagen
oder ob sie zu viel angst haben und
möglicherweise dann die angeklagten doch
ungeschoren davonkommen
frank man hat den eindruck oft wenn der
klaren ist vor gericht stehen dann haben
die irgendwelche tricks wie sie dann
doch wieder einer gefängnisstrafe
entgehen wie ist dein eindruck wie wird
es dort wohl ausgehen was welches
strafmaß steht da im raum und was kann
er noch dazwischen kommen für
überraschungen was sich die kleinen
mitglieder ausdenken
naja da steht schon ein hohes strafmaß
dem raum auch wenn die anklage noch
relativ jung sind und nicht vorbestraft
jedenfalls nicht schwerwiegend wären sie
wahrscheinlich mit doch möglicherweise
medien haftstrafen rechnen müssen bis zu
zehn jahre sind möglich schwerer raub
vergewaltigung im raum nur genau was ich
gerade beschrieben haben dafür müssen
die zeugenaussagen und wenn diese frauen
und das sind ja die tat zeugen sie sind
bedroht worden sie sind geschlagen
worden sie sind beraubt und
eingeschüchtert worden und wenn die
jetzt angst haben und nicht aussagen
dann könnte das natürlich genau wieder
der punkt sein den berlin immer wieder
passiert ist arafat und seine brüder und
auch teilweise andere familienmitglieder
sind immer wieder angeklagt worden wenn
wir vor gericht gestanden aber wirklich
hier vorstrafen sind nicht mehr um
gekommen weil zeugen sich plötzlich
nicht mehr erinnern konnten nicht mehr
aufgetaucht sind oder gar nichts mehr
gesagt haben und die gefahr besteht
natürlich in diesem prozess auch und das
wäre natürlich verheerend für unseren
rechtsstaat wenn sie es wieder erneut
schaffen sorgen so einzuschüchtern dass
sie nicht aussagen man kann nur hoffen
dass die zeugen trotzdem hut haben und
sich von der polizei geschützt fühlen
und ihre aussage hier im gerichtssaal
machen werden dank an unser bild
chefreporter frank schneider über diesen
großen klaren prozess heute dort vom
landgericht in bochum der sohn von
arafat abou chaker dem chef dieser
klaren familie er steht da heute vor
gericht danke dir frank